[Música]
சранமி
சரமி
[Música]
சн
சர
[Música]
দুан
புத
சரனти
[Música]
Paman
saran.
[Música]
nam
Ara
sambud.
[Música]
Dedicamos nossa prática todos os budas e
patriarcas que mantiveram acesa luz do
dharmo por inúmeras gerações.
Aos benfeitores e benfeitoras do dharma
vivos e falecidos. aos nossos ancestrais
e a todos os seres que morreram para
nossa sobrevivência.
Dedicamos nossa prática as pessoas vivas
e as pessoas falecidas aqui
relacionadas,
para que com uma luz que dissipa a
escuridão, o avorecer de dar mata e das
cinco sabedoria se complete,
conduzindo-as à liberação das
enfermidades, aflições e confusão, e
capacitando-as a agir em benefício de
todos os seres. Dedicamos a lucidez e a
realização de todos os seres em todas as
direções e tempos. Todos
e as causas da felicidade e superem o
sofrimento e as causas do sofrimento.
Hoje nós vamos dedicar a nossa prática,
especialmente à remoção de obstáculos e
longa vida do Ricardo Avelini, Dar João
Alifax
também.
pela remoção de obstáculos de longa vida
do Dr. Cels Dr.
Olavo Ker, da Andreia Noque, da dona Isa
Zoque, da Mari Girard, da Vitória Dil e
seus familiares
também da Regina Augusta Carvalho
Teixeira,
da Beatriz Rocha e sua mãe Paula Rocha,
do Moisés Tadeu Sequim Cabeleira,
também o Luís Felipe Jornada Cabeleira,
Paulo Servolo, a Felicidade de Souza
também a Fabiana Bernardon,
a Marisa Cedrel e a dona Elsa Paz, o os
professores Cláudio Fiorese e Leandra,
sua esposa da Sanga do Caminho do Meio,
também a Samira
Pinto,
o João Carlos Resler,
e um número
de pessoas falecidas, as vítimas das
guerras incessantes,
os palestinos mortos na invasão de seus
territórios,
o Luís Artur Aveline de Oliveira, sua
eminência, Lopon Tenzin Nand Rimpochê,
José Antônio de Sá, pai da Flori, que
faleceu hoje, dia primeiro dia.
Sim.
Tá. E aqui duas fontes diferentes
mandaram isso. Mandaram para pra Andela
botou na lista, né?
Foi, né? Então, então o nós estamos
anunciando
eh, então nós vamos colocá-lo na
prática de remoção de obstáculos, né?
Então, José Antônio de Sá tá em cuidados
paliativos
e nós vamos dedicar também a outras
pessoas falecidas, como a Priscila
Moisés Araújo,
o Marcos e a Giovana,
o a Maria Portilho de Oliveira Costa,
a Joana Meice, a mestra Jonse,
a senhora Onestina Rosa Fcker
também, Arnaldo Carvalho, Antônio Sérgio
Falcão,
Thago Costa Dominguez, Juvêncio Canho,
Cristine Canales da Trindade
e os Pais da Guta, o Divino Teixeira e a
dona Celina Eunice Carvalho Teixeira.
A internet tá muito ruim. Eu acho que é
isso né?
Porque tá caindo o tempo todo. Cai e
volta.
Deixa eu ver aqui.
Ah,
>> ele voltou paraa Casa Verde. Aí eu tô
colocando templo aqui.
[Música]
Guru
de
[Música]
passa à minha frente, mãe de todos os
vitoriosos. Tara de fato aparece a ele.
Eu rezo agora enquanto eu, incontáveis
outras pessoas, estamos perdidos no
oceano do sofrimento sansárico, busco a
iluminação para adquirir a felicidade
temporária e definitiva para mim e para
todos os seres vivos. Por esse motivo,
toma o refúgio em área a corporificação
do puro estado desperto e indissociável
de todas as qualidades perfeitas do
Buda, Dharma, Sanga, Lama, Idan e
Daquini. Agora, enquanto eu incontáveis
outras pessoas, estamos perdidos no
oceano do sofrimento sansárico,
felicidade temporária definitiva para
mim e para todos os seres vivos. Por
esse motivo, toma o refúgio em Ariatara,
a corporificação do puro estado
desperto, indissociável de todas as
qualidades perfeitas do Buda, Dharma,
Sanga, Lama, Idan e Daquini. Agora,
enquanto eu incontáveis outras pessoas
no Oceano do Sofrimento Sansárico, busco
a iluminação para adquirir a felicidade
temporária definitiva para mim e para
todos os seres vivos. Por esse motivo,
tomo refúgio em areatara, a
corporificação do puro estado desperto,
indissociável de todas as qualidades
perfeitas do Buda, dharma, sanga, lama,
e daquini. Do fundo do coração rezo,
evocando da testa garganta e coração de
Tara
nas cores do arco-íris. A medida que os
raios de luz tocam a mim e a todos os
outros seres, os frutos venenosos do
karma negativo, doenças, aflições
demoníacas e obstáculos evaporam-se como
orvalho sobre o sol da manhã. Mérito,
sabedoria, glória, riqueza e longevidade
aumentam além de qualquer medida. Ó
ilustre Tara, por favor, tenha
consciência de mim, remova meus
obstáculos e rapidamente conceda minhas
excelentes aspirações.
[Música]
Sandra
com
[Música]
com s
Sono
[Música]
com
Pag
mačin
[Música]
com
sandom
[Música]
tet
Tra
[Música]
아,
Tá
tão
tare
tor
[Música]
On
sare
[Música]
tão
tare
soltar
[Música]
tor
os milhões de universos, o monte Meruz,
os quatro continentes, os continentes
menores, o esplendor e a glória dos
deuses na humanos, juntamente com suas
raízes de virtude.
Não v de oferendas perfeitamente puras.
Eu as ofereço a Tara, mãe dos
vitoriosos.
Hraonom.
os bilhões de universos, o monte Meruz,
quatro continentes, os continentes
menores, o esplendor e a glória dos
deuses naas e humanos, juntamente com
suas raízes de virtude,
emanam como enormes e extensas nuvens de
oferendas perfeitamente puras. Eu as
ofereço a Tara, mãe dos vitoriosos.
Ron,
os bilhões de universos, o monte Meru,
os quatro continentes, os continentes
menores, o esplendor e a glória dos
deuses naas e humanos, juntamente com
suas raízes de virtude, emanam como
enormes e extensas nuvens de oferendas
perfeitamente puras. Eu as ofereço a
Tara, mãe dos vitoriosos,
tranguro, ratna mandala.
pela força desta oração feita com o
coração, que a mente iluminada possa ser
conquistada e que as aparências possam
ser percebidas com pureza como sendo o
corpo da deidade, que o significado dos
estágios
da consumação possa ser naturalmente
internalizado,
que as condições não auspiciosas para o
caminho perfeito possam ser pacificadas
e que todas as aspirações e condições
auspiciosas concebíveis possam ser
preenchidas, que máculas e
obscurecimentos da não virtude
e que o mal proveniente de outros seres
e os sonhos ruins possam ser evitados.
Conceda a bênção da proteção para o medo
dos estados inferiores de existência.
Posso o renascimento não ocorrer nas
oito condições onde não há oportunidade
para a prática. Que todas as vidas
possam ser lembradas e que as faculdades
possam ser lúcidas. Possa a disciplina
ser pura e a mente voltar-se para o
dharma contra o amadurecimento do karma
causado pelas ilusões. Conceda a bênção
que escuda, protege e oculta. que o
poder adverso dos inimigos, demônios,
interferências fantasmagóricas,
os efeitos nocivos da morte
extemporânea, epidemias e doenças
causadas por venenos possam ser todos
pacificados e purificados e que as
sabedoria, as atividades de Tara possam
ser reveladas no reino puro dos
vitoriosos, que a presença espontânea
dos três caias encontra-se Ela que dá
nascimento aos vitoriosos dos três
tempos, uma nuvem inexaurível com a
felicidade dos três segredos. Próstro-me
diante de você, ó guia sublime.
A partir de agora e até que alcance a
iluminação, vou confiar em você como
minha única fonte de refúgio, proteção.
De acordo com suas aspirações e
compromissos pregressos, não hesite em
sua compaixão. Conceda plenamente a mim
seus poderes, bênçãos e sides. Todo
aquele que me vir, me ouvir, me tocar ou
se lembrar de mim, por esses que são
quatro meios de liberação e pelo mais
sublimicide,
possa eu ser capaz de liberar todos que
estão ligados a mim e possa minha
realização tornar-se igual à sua. Sem
recorrer ao poder da imantação,
poderia alguém adquirir as qualidades
necessárias para cuidar dos outros?
possa eu influenciar todos os seres a
serem pacificados,
positivos e negativos, sem exceção, ao
inspirar neles os quatro tipos de
devoção. Além disso, ao conquistar as
qualidades positivas do estado da
liberação, que todos os seres possam
conseguir rapidamente a forma efetiva
dos vitoriosos,
resplandescente com as marcas maiores e
menores da perfeição.
até tal momento possamos estar livres
dos oito grandes medos e de influências
malévolas, possam florescer qualidades
favoráveis como longevidade, glória e
excelência. Que a yoga dos dois estágios
possa ser conquistada e que possamos
ficar livres de obstáculos. Que em todos
os países a doença, a guerra e a fome
possam ser pacificados.
possuir alegria, felicidade sublime e
praticar o dharma. Que os ensinamentos
do Buda possam ser propagados e que
todos os seres possam se abrigar sob
orientação de Tara, mãe dos vitoriosos.
Que em todos os países a doença, a
guerra e a fome possam ser pacificados.
Que todos os seres possam possuir
alegria, felicidade sublime e praticar o
dharma. Que os ensinamentos do Buda
possam ser propagados e que todos os
seres possam se abrigar sob orientação
de Tara, mãe dos vitoriosos. Que em
todos os países a doença, a guerra e a
fome possam ser pacificados.
Que todos os seres possam possuir
alegria, felicidade sublime e praticar o
dharma. Que os ensinamentos do Buda
possam ser propagados e que todos os
seres possam se abrigar sob orientação
de Tara, mãe dos vitoriosos. O apego às
aparências comuns e a minha forma
corpórea se desfaz. No espaço da
vacuidade aparece espontaneamente.
Desperto natural de minha mente com a
sílaba raiz tam de cor vermelha
brilhante. Instantaneamente Tam se
transforma na forma luminosa da nobre
Tara. Ela está sorrindo, é extremamente
bela. Sua mão direita faz o gesto da
suprema generosidade
e segura um vaso de longa vida. Sua mão
esquerda faz o gesto das três joias e
segura pela aste uma flor de pala
vermelha. Dentro das pétalas da flor há
um arco e flecha totalmente esticados,
feitos de delicadas flores. Suas vestes
são feitas de requintada seda,
graciosamente drapeada, que a recobre
com perfeição. Ela usa joias que
realizam desejos e ornamentos
esplêndidos. Bem como uma guirlanda de
flores de lótos. Metade de seu cabelo
está preso no alto da cabeça, metade cai
sobre as costas. Ela está sentada na
postura do conforto real, sobre um disco
do sol repousado sobre um lótus
vermelho. Uma lua cheia aparece por trás
dela. O budam está sentado sobre um
lótus acima de sua cabeça. Ela tem cor
vermelha como rubi. Seu blírio glorioso
se radia com as cores do arco-íris,
preenchendo uma esfera infinita. sobre
um lótus vermelho, um disco do sol em
seu coração, a sílaba racada
pelo mala de mantra. À medida que o
mantra é recitado, um mala de mantra
começa a girar. A luz que se radia do
mala forma oferendas para os budas e
bodissáas das 10 direções, retornando
como bênçãos de sabedoria, a luz é
reabsorvida.
A luz se radia novamente para os seres
dos seis reinos, dissolvendo todo o
sofrimento e transformando tudo nos
fenômenos imaculados da terra pura de
Tara.
Soar
tare
tón
[Música]
Tor
t
[Música]
Tan, so on
tara
[Música]
sor.
Nós seguimos agora a nossa prática
dedicando a remoção de obstáculos e
longa vida das pessoas que a gente
queira lembrar especialmente.
Taret tão sorrão. Taret tão su
taretão. Taretão suan.
Tá detrão. Tá detrão. Tá
dando s.
Per
Dançou.
Ten sua
tetão. Tão sol.
Taret
umaretan.
Agora nós seguimos a nossa prática
dedicando à remoção de obstáculo das
pessoas falecidas.
Do coração de Tar emana uma luz de
arco-íris para os seis reinos e para o
bardo, envolvendo as pessoas falecidas
onde quer que estejam, purificando seu
karma e asindo com as bênçãos radiantes
de Tara. Suas formas se transformam em
brilhantes esferas de luz que se
dissolvem na mente coração de Tara. Um
reino além dos ciclos de sofrimento, um
reino de absoluta pureza e felicidade.
Tar sua Tá, tão su tão su tão su tão su
tão tão
Tam
Tetão su
taretão suaretan.
Ah!
Passamos agora pra prática do prag na
paramita.
Concebível inexprimível prágam
não nascida, incessante, por natureza
semelhante ao céu, experienciada pela
cognição discriminativa aprístina da
consciência autorreflexiva,
mãe de todos os vitoriosos dos três
tempos, a você presta homenagem o
coração da bem-aventurada
prágina paramita. Homenagem a Bagavate
Pragna Paramita. Assim eu ouvi. Uma vez
o abençoado estava residindo em
Rajagria, na montanha do pico dos
abutres. Junto com ele estava um grande
grupo da sangue
dos bodissátuas.
Em dado momento, o abençoado entorno
Samad, que examina os diferentes tipos
de dharma chamado profunda iluminação.
E ao mesmo tempo nobrectesvar,
bodissatua mahasa, enquanto praticava
profunda prágina paramita, viu que os
cinco escândalas eram vazios por
natureza. Então, pelo poder do Buda, o
venerável Chariputra disse ao nobre
abaltezara bodsatua,
como deveria proceder o filho ou a filha
de nobres qualidades que quisesse
praticar a profunda prágina paramita?
por ter sido perguntado dessa forma, o
nobrectes
bodsatua,
disse ao venerável chariputra: "Ó
Chariputra, um filho, uma filha de
nobres qualidades que desejasse praticar
a profunda prágina paramita deveria
haver assim: os cinco escândalas t a
natureza da vacuidade.
Forme é vazio, vazio é forma. Forma nada
mais é do que vazio. Vazio nada mais é
do que forma. Do mesmo modo, sensação,
percepção, formação mental e consciência
são todos vacuidade. Assim, Chariputra,
todos os dharmas são vacuidade. Não tem
características, são não nascidos e não
cessam, nem impuros e nem livres da
impureza, nem decrescem e nem crescem.
Portanto, chareputra, a vacuidade não
tem forma, nem sensação, nem percepção,
nem formação mental, nem consciência.
Não tem olhos, ouvidos, nariz, língua,
corpo e mente. Não tem aparência, som,
cheiro, sabor, tato e objetos da mente.
Não tem os elementos de consciências
relacionados aos olhos e aos demais
sentidos físicos. E não tem mente ou
elemento de consciência da mente, não
tem ignorância, nem extinção da
ignorância, nem os elos subsequentes até
velice e morte e a extinção de velice e
morte. Do mesmo modo, não há sofrimento
ou origem do sofrimento ou extinção do
sofrimento, nem caminho, nem sabedoria,
nem realização, nem não realização.
Portanto, chariputra, uma vez que os
bodsátuas não têm nada para atingir,
eles se manifestam através da confiança
na prágina paramita. Uma vez que não há
obcuridades mentais, não há medos,
transcendendo completamente as visões
falsas, atinge o derradeiro Nirvana.
Todos os budas dos três tempos, por
repousarem na prágina paramita, atingem
completamente a iluminação perfeita e
insuperável. Portanto, o mantra da
prágina paramita, o mantra da
é um mantra insuperável, o mantre que
torna igual, que é desigual, o mantre
que pacifica por inteiro todo o
sofrimento. Uma vez que não produz
engano, deveria ser reconhecido como
verdadeiro. O mantra da prágina paramita
é recitado assim:
para
tempor
[Música]
paraangate
paragang
parag paraangate
paragate paraangate
paragate
Parag paraangate
paragang
parag paraang
parag paraangate
paragang
paragate paraangate
paragate
Xputra. É dessa forma que o bodama
deveria treinar-se na profunda prágam.
Então o abençoado retornou de seu samade
e louvou nobre valctesvar bodsata,
dizendo: "Muito bom, muito bom, ó filho
de nobres qualidades. Assim é, assim é,
é exatamente como ensinou. Deve-se
praticar a profunda prágina paramita.
Todos os tatágatas irão pel". Quando
abençoado pronunciou essas palavras, o
venerável Chariputre, o nobre
valôcteusvara, o bodátua mahçátua, junto
com toda a assembleia e todo o mundo,
com seus deuses humanos, Azuras e
Gandarbas, todos se alegraram louvando
que o abençoado havia dito. Isso conclui
o sutra do coração da bem-aventurada
Prajna Paramita.
Nós passamos agora paraa prática do Buda
da medicina.
Toma refúgio Nuguro, o Buda da medicina,
em quem as três joias se unem e incita o
bodetita para o benefício dos seres.
Toma o refúgio no guro, o Buda da
medicina, em quem as três joias se unem
e incita bodetita para benefício dos
seres. Toma o refúgio no guru, o Buda da
medicina, em quem as três joias se unem.
em citabodeta,
para o benefício dos seres. R forma de
estar é isenta das limitações da
elaboração.
O solo, morada do ser, o supremamente
bem-aventurado Buda da medicina, azul,
negro, escuro, pacífico e sorridente,
brilhando numa auréula de luz. Sua mão
direita segura o rei dos medicamentos no
gesto da perfeita generosidade
e à esquerda uma tigela de mendicante no
gesto do equilíbrio meditativo
completo com todas as marcas maiores e
menores da perfeição. Ele veste trages
do nirmanakia.
Ele está sentado sobre um lótus e um
disco de lua na postura vágra. Em seu
coração, sobre um lótus e um disco de
lua, está a sílaba rom circundada pelo
mantra, enquanto, repito, o poço da
existência cíclica é dragado desde suas
profundezas.
aromaz
bek
[Música]
Bazka
bk
bhak
samate
sok
Baz하
[Música]
Braz
Bazk
Baz
So
behak
sam하
BKZ BKZ BKZ
BK BK BK
BK BK
[Música]
Homenagem. Ó Buda da medicina que tudo
permeia
do ver. Você dissipa nossos sofrimentos
e enfermidades.
Você concede as qualidades dos caias e o
estado desperto atemporal. Curvo-me
diante de você e o louvo. Você que é o
esplendor da total perfeição.
O aspecto manifesto se dissolve no
espaço básico.
por meio dessa virtude, que todos os
seres possam alcançar o estado búdico
rapidamente.
Nós passamos agora pra prática de
vagraçtua.
O ambiente é canista. O topo da nossa
cabeça vai jurartua e com sorte não
doais na forma de uma esfera branca
brilhante.
Dessa imagem desce um fio de néctar
perolado que penetra o topo da nossa
cabeça.
Enquanto seguimos a prática, passa a
preencher o nosso corpo que se
transforma progressivamente no corpo
branco brilhante perfeito de
vágeratua.
As raízes de ignorância, doenças,
aflições e sofrimentos
se esgotam pelo chakra básico e pela
pele.
Ao final nós repousamos
inseparáveis de vassatua
samá manopalá
tenai
bacai
norá
pr saram
[Música]
Bagonaruata
benza
satama
palayá
baá caiuato
pr sarma
seriam
bagata
Omраvom
важвам
ом важрасатвам
ом важ
Satra
[Música]
Satrava
on vaat
Satu on vaat
V são. Satu
para tu
vai já vouar
um pato
Satu
vai sваat
Tam.
Vatão. Vatão.
Vai são. Vai.
da Satváва
um
por meio dessa virtude, que todos os
seres possam cansar o estado búdico
rapidamente.
com salindro
partir.
[Música]
G
Beg Pelom
Guru
[Música]
Só
nós vamos
ah interromper aqui antes do da
dedicação começaria agora, né? Então eu
vou eu vou seguir um pouco o nosso
estudo, um tanto assim, não muito, aí a
gente avançou um pouco, né? Então a
gente vai pra página 20 agora.
Ofer de sete ramos através de
homenagens oferendas confissão
regozijo, solicitação e súplica.
Qualquer pequeno mérito que eu tenha
gerado, dedico a que todos possam
alcançar a iluminação.
A terra está ungida com água perfumada,
espargida de flores e adornada pelo
Sumero, os quatro continentes, o sol e a
lua. Por eu ter imaginado e oferecido
isso como um reino búdico, possam todos
os seres usufruir dos reinos puros. A
terra está ungida com água perfumada,
espargida de flores e adornada pelo
Sumero, os quatro continentes, o sol e a
lua. Por eu ter imaginado e oferecido
isso como um reino búdico, possam todos
os seres usufruir dos reinos puros. A
terra está ungida com água perfumada,
espargida de flores e adornada pelo
Sumero, os quatro continentes, o sol e a
lua. Por eu ter imaginado e oferecido
isso como um reino búdico, possam todos
os seres usufruir dos reinos puros:
Hidan guru mandala canria taiame.
Para satisfazer as necessidades de todos
os seres em seus diversos níveis de
compreensão,
solicitamos a você que gire a roda do
dharma, incluindo as abordagens menores
e maiores, comuns e extraordinárias.
Através deste mérito que todos os seres
se tornaram oniscientes e alcançaram o
estado bdico, derrotando todas as faltas
e impedimentos.
Que todos os seres possam ser liberados
do oceano da existência condicionada,
agitado pelas ondas de nascimento da
velice, da doença e da morte.
Então,
eu vou seguir um pouco mais. A gente
tinha parado,
nós íamos continuar justamente na parte
dos cinco elementos, né? Então, a gente
tinha olhado repolsas partes do corpo.
Então, o Buda segue novamente bicos.
Um um bico examina esse mesmo corpo e
não importando sua posição
ou postura,
que não importando sua posição ou
postura, consiste de elementos da
seguinte forma. Nesse corpo há o
elemento terra, o elemento água, o
elemento fogo e o elemento ar.
Então aqui isso é super importante,
pessoal, porque a gente olha isso como
se fosse tudo denso, né?
Mas aqui a gente vai
olhar os elementos e os elementos nós
vamos ver como uma experiência e essa
experiência nós vamos ver como uma
manifestação
luminosa.
Então a sensação dos elementos é uma é
uma experiência
delusiva.
Então nesse corpo há o elemento terra, o
elemento água, o elemento fogo, o
elemento ar. Do mesmo modo, como se um
açogueiro habilidoso ou seu aprendiz
tivesse matado uma vaca e estivesse
sentado numa encruzilhada com a vaca em
pedaços, assim também um bico examina
esse mesmo corpo que consiste de
elementos.
Esse corpo é o elemento terra, o
elemento água, o elemento fogo, elemento
ar.
Portanto, nesse corpo há o elemento
terra, elemento água, elemento fogo,
elemento ar.
Da mesma forma, ele permanece
contemplando o corpo como um corpo
internamente externamente tanto
interna quanto externamente.
E ele permanece independente,
sem nenhum apego a qualquer coisa
mundana. Assim também é como um bico
permanece contemplando o corpo como um
corpo.
Então a gente volta sempre para essa
parte que é que é
que ele vai chamar de de
insite, né? Dessa forma, ele permanece
contemplando o corpo como um corpo
internamente e ele permanece
externamente. Ou ele permanece
contemplando o corpo como um corpo tanto
interna quanto externamente.
Ou então ele permanece contemplando os
fenômenos que surgem no corpo e ele
permanece contemplando os fenômenos que
desaparecem no corpo e ele permanece
contemplando ambos os fenômenos que
surgem, os fenômenos que desaparecem no
corpo.
Então a atenção plena de que existe um
corpo se estabelece somente na medida
necessária para o conhecimento e para a
continuidade da atenção plena. E ele
permanece independente, sem nenhum apego
a qualquer coisa mundana. Assim é como
um bico permanece contemplando o corpo
como um corpo.
Então ele vai seguindo assim, né? Tudo
isso é contemplação do corpo, né?
Em cada uma das partes, ele sempre vai
dizer isso.
Então aqui a gente olhou os cinco
elementos. Aí na sequência nós temos as
nove contemplações do cemitério, que eu
queria falar isso à noite assim porque
fica melhor.
Novamente bicos, os fantasmas, quer
dizer, não, como se ele visse um cadáver
jogado num cemitério assim à noite, um,
dois ou três dias depois de morto,
inchado, lívido e esvaindo matéria.
Um bico compara o seu corpo com aquele.
Esse corpo, seja o próprio, também tem a
mesma natureza, se tornará igual, não
está isento deste destino.
Dessa forma, ele permanece contemplando
o corpo como um corpo internamente,
externamente,
tanto interna quanto externamente.
e aquelas classificações todas. E ele
permanece independente,
sem nenhum apego a qualquer coisa
mondana.
Então, esse independente é o ponto
principal. Eh, dentro da desse
independente surge a experiência da
própria vacuidade,
sem nenhum apego a qualquer coisa
mundana. Assim também é como um bico
permanece contemplando o corpo como um
corpo
novamente, como se lhe visse um cadáver
jogado em um cemitério,
sendo devorado por corvos,
gaviões,
abutres cães chacais
ou vários tipos de verme,
um bico compara o seu corpo com aquele
Esse corpo também tem a mesma natureza,
se tornará igual, não está isento deste
destino.
Assim também é como um bico permanece
contemplando o corpo como um corpo.
Então ele olha e ele ele vai ganhando,
ele vai ficando independente.
Na verdade, enquanto ele vai olhando
esses objetos, ele vai ganhando uma
familiaridade com a natureza livre da
mente, que não é nenhuma dessas partes.
E ele vai se familiarizando com esse
ponto livre que ele olha
novamente novamente bicos.
Novamente bicos.
como se ele visse um cadáver jogado num
cemitério,
um esqueleto com carne e sangue que se
mantém unido por tendões.
Um esqueleto descarnado
e aí um pouco adiante, né? Um esqueleto
descarnado, lambusado de sangue, que se
mantém unido por tendões.
Aí mais adiante, um esqueleto descarnado
e sem sangue, que se mantém unido por
tendões.
Mais adiante, ol ossos desconectados,
espalhados em todas as direções.
Aqui um osso da mão. Ali um osso do pé.
Aqui um osso da perna. Ali um osso da
coxa. Aqui um osso da bacia. Ali um osso
da coluna vertebral. Aqui uma costela,
ali um osso do peito. Aqui um osso do
braço. Ali um osso do ombro. Aqui um
osso do pescoço. Ali um osso da
mandíbula, aqui um dente. Aqui um
crânio.
Um bico compara o seu corpo com aquele.
Portanto, esse corpo também tem a mesma
natureza, se tornará igual. Não está
isento deste destino.
Assim é.
Assim também é como um bico permanece
contemplando um corpo como um corpo.
Novamente, bicos, como se lhe visse um
cadáver jogado em um cemitério,
os ossos brancos desbotados,
a cor de conchas,
ossos amontoados com mais de um ano.
Osso, ou mais adiante, né? Ossos
apodrecidos e esfarelados, convertidos
em pó.
Um bico compara o seu corpo com aquele,
esse corpo também tem a mesma natureza,
se tornará igual, não está isento desse
destino.
E aí vem o insite.
Dessa forma, ele permanece contemplando
o corpo como um corpo internamente
ou ele permanece contemplando o corpo
como um corpo externamente,
como um corpo, tanto interna quanto
externamente.
Ou então ele permanece contemplando
fenômenos que surgem no corpo, ou ele
permanece contemplando fenômenos que
desaparecem no corpo, ou ele permanece
contemplando ambos fenômenos que surgem
e fenômenos que desaparecem no corpo. Ou
então a atenção plena de que existe um
corpo se estabelece somente na medida
necessária para o conhecimento e para a
continuidade da da atenção plena. E ele
permanece independente, sem nenhum apego
a qualquer coisa mundana.
Assim é como um bico permanece
contemplando o corpo no corpo,
ou seja, ele permanece independente, sem
nenhum apego a qualquer coisa mundana.
Então, ainda que ele veja tudo, ele
reconhece que o próprio corpo dele pode
passar por isso, tá vulnerável a isso,
ah, ele se mantém independente, ele se
mantém livre.
Assim é como um bico permanece
contemplando o corpo no corpo.
E vem agora vem a contemplação das
sensações.
E como bicos, um bico permanece
contemplando sensações como sensações.
Aqui quando sente uma sensação
prazerosa, um bico compreende. Eu sinto
uma sensação prazerosa.
Quando sente uma sensação dolorosa,
ele compreende: "Eu sinto uma sensação
dolorosa."
Quando sente uma sensação nem prazerosa,
nem dolorosa,
ele compreende. Eu sinto uma sensação
nem prazerosa, nem dolorosa.
Quando sente uma sensação prazerosa,
mundana, ele compreende. Eu sinto uma
sensação prazerosa, mundana.
Quando sente uma sensação prazerosa, não
mundana, ele compreende. Eu sinto uma
sensação prazerosa, não mundana. Quando
sente uma sensação dolorosa mundana, ele
compreende. Eu sinto uma sensação
dolorosa, mundana. Quando sente uma
sensação dolorosa, não mundana, ele
compreende. Eu sinto uma sensação
dolorosa, não mundana. Quando sente uma
sensação nem prazerosa, nem dolorosa,
mundana, ele compreende. Eu sinto uma
sensação
nem prazerosa, nem dolorosa, mundana,
quando sente uma sensação nem prazerosa,
nem dolorosa, não mundana. Ele
compreende. Eu sinto uma sensação nem
prazerosa, nem dolorosa,
não mundana.
Aí vem a visão, insite.
Então, a gente tava no corpo, né? Agora
a gente passou paraas sensações.
Ele diz dessa forma, o Buda diz dessa
forma o bico permanece contemplando as
sensações como sensações
internamente
e ele permanece contemplando as
sensações como sensações
externamente.
Ou ele permanece contemplando as
sensações como sensações tanto interna
quanto externamente.
Ou então ele permanece contemplando
fenômenos que surgem nas sensações ou
ele permanece contemplando fenômenos que
desaparecem nas sensações.
Ele permanece contemplando ambos
fenômenos que surgem e fenômenos que
desaparecem nas sensações.
Ou então atenção plena de que existem
sensações se estabelece somente na
medida necessária
para o conhecimento e para a
continuidade da tensão plena.
E ele permanece independente, sem nenhum
apego a qualquer coisa mundana. Assim é
como um bico
permanece contemplando sensações
como sensações.
Então nós vamos parar nessa parte aqui.
Então essencialmente ele ele ganha uma
independência em relação a tudo que ele
vê como corpo e a tudo que ele vê como
sensação.
É isso. Ele obtém isso. Não rejeitando,
mas olhando.
É assim. Então eu vou
parar nesse ponto e se tiver alguma
pergunta a gente segue
por favor.
Como é que é? se contempla externamente
as sensações.
>> É como se fosse uma outra coisa.
É como se a gente tivesse separado
delas né?
>> E contemplara internamente é como
>> a gente tá identificado assim total, né?
>> Ah,
prática fazer dois cosas.
identificar la pricidarse
con
dos experiencias
con identificentro
o desidentificar contemplar como un
fenomeno
[Música]
ambas que por vezes a gente vê de um
jeito, por vezes a gente vê de outro
jeito.
Naturalmente quando a gente tá imerso
nas coisas, né?
E então nós estamos desenraizando o
automatismo que vem disso,
>> mas o ponto central seria de permanecer
independente.
>> É, essencialmente nós estamos definindo
isso, mas esse é o aspecto mais
aparente. Mas na verdade
nós estamos nos familiarizando com uma
natureza livre e lúcida, que não entra
em nenhuma experiência. nem de corpo,
nem de sensação, nem de mente e nem das
construções da mente, né?
Esse é o ponto. Então, tudo que aparece
tá ligado a esses quatro aspectos.
Então, eu tô ganhando uma liberdade
frente a todas as essas manifestações
que, por sua vez, originam os
pensamentos e originam as reações todas,
né?
E essa seria uma compreensão basada na
natural perfecção sobre esse sutra ou
está intrinsecamente já na sutra?
>> Ah, eu diria que a natural perfeição tá
intrínseca nele, né? Mas aqui a conexão
que a gente tem é que nós estamos nos
defrontando com com aparências e
experiências variadas que a gente pode
tomar como como um treinamento paraa
parte de ahção.
Então, nós temos visão, meditação e aí
nós começamos a contemplar diferentes
coisas que nos perturbariam e dariam um
sentido verdadeiro, que nos fariam nos
fariam
reagir e se movimentar dentro de um
mundo aparente, das bolhas aparentes.
Então nós começamos a localizar isso e
desenraizar esse automatismo,
esse aspecto de eh de reconhecer
independência,
ele nem rejeita, nem se fixa, nem deixa
de ver, mas ele tá independente.
Então, nós estamos ah reconhecendo
aquilo que poderia ser dito dentro do
praj na paramita como confiança no praj
paramita.
Pra paramita a gente vai dizer, a gente
vai descrever tudo, vai cuidade disso,
facidade daquilo, na facuidade não há
isso, não há aquilo, etc, etc. E aí
nós vamos dizer que os bodáfas, marrass
repousam na confiança no prag na
paramita.
Essa parte ela é ela conecta diretamente
com o guru yoga. Essa confiança é
essencialmente guru yoga. No próprio
prág paramita. Depois nós vamos dizer
que todos os budas e bodátuas dos três
tempos atingem a iluminação
desse modo. Então pela confiança no praj
paramitana.
Então essa confiança é guru yoga e é uma
ligação com todos os budas e budistatas.
dos três tempos, né? Então, eh nós vamos
perceber que as nossas identidades se
definem pelo jeito pelo qual nós
respondemos aos fenômenos de corpo e aos
fenômenos de eh das sensações, né?
Então, nós temos padrões para responder
a isso e desse modo nós ficamos eh nós
nos definimos.
E aqui ele tá descrevendo a
independência e a lucidez
diante de todos esses fenômenos.
Isso é essencialmente
a confiança na visão.
Essa confiança na visão, ela não impede,
como tá se vendo, que os que o corpo
seja visto, que o corpo seja operado,
que as sensações sejam vistas, não
impede nada. Nós estamos vendo.
Então ele permanece contemplando
os fenômenos nas sensações. Ele ele
contempla tudo,
mas ele não dá um sentido final. Por
isso ele pode beneficiar os seres.
Quando os seres estão presos nesses
ambientes, o dharma vem e pode ajudar.
Se ele rejeitasse, se ele negasse, ele
não conseguiria ajudar. Se ele não
visse, se ele se eximisse de não ver,
não focar, se ele considerasse que a
lucidez é não ver, aí ele não
conseguiria ajudar também.
Como que o outro sentindo a gente sente.
É isso,
né? Como é que a compaixão surge, né?
Como é que vem a uneisciência?
Eu
diria que o
eu acho sempre interessante a gente
observar quando vai olhar a
a vacuidade, de olhar sempre a bolha,
né? Porque a bolha a gente vê surgir. Aí
quando nós olhamos os fenômenos dentro
das bolhas, a gente sabe que são
fenômenos delusivos, não duais,
né? Aquilo fica direto, né? Se a gente
vai analisar fenômeno por fenômeno, é
difícil.
Pode falar, João.
>> Boa noite, Lama. Eh, na minha prática,
como eu tenho uma memória meio ruim, eu
senti que o suta ele tem uma série de
situações como se fosse um roteiro assim
do que ser analisado, né?
Eh, como eu não ia conseguir gravar,
>> não tá ouvindo bem, não sei bem por
>> hã tá ruim
>> agora. Sim,
>> melhorou.
>> Melhorou. É porque tava apanhado isso no
Sutra tem uma série de situações quase
como se fosse um roteiro assim para ser
seguido e ser analisado. Só que como eu
tenho uma memória ruim, eu tinha acabado
de conhecer o texto, eu não fiquei muito
pegado nessa nesse roteiro a ser
seguido. Eu peguei mais essa situação,
por exemplo, que o senhor acabou de
falar de perceber os fenômenos como
fenômenos do corpo, fenômenos como
sensação, fenômenos como formação
mental, elaboração mental mais paraa
frente. E aí eu analisava dentro dessas
quatro características assim, se isso é
um fenômeno de corpo, é um fenômeno de
sensação mental. Normalmente eu percebia
que o de corpo era ia subindo até chegar
à conclusão de que não existia nada e aí
descansava quase que na nessa última
afirmação agora. Ascensão plena no corpo
se estabelece apenas na medida
necessária para o estabelecimento da
sensão plena. Por isso que eu fiquei um
pouco confuso no final se era um vipasna
ou um
chamata. Porque toda essa análise, ela,
apesar, eu não sei, eu fiquei na dúvida
se eu tava fazendo certo ou errado,
porque eu não tava seguindo o roteiro do
suta, mas eu fiquei tentando analisar
dentro desses quatro percepções assim,
sabe, tudo que ia surgindo. E foi mais
ou menos isso. Aí eu fiquei na dúvida se
eu tava fazendo certo, se eu tava
fazendo errado, se era necessário ler o
texto até decorar o roteiro ou se era e
o essencial essas percepção dessas
quatro níveis de sensação de atenção
plena. Eu fiquei um pouco com essa
dúvida.
>> Eu acho que tinha que entrar nesses
detalhes, sabe, João? Tinha que olhar
isso, ou seja, tinha que ver os seguir o
roteiro,
imaginar situações específicas e aí ver
como é que tu reage ali dentro, ver se
aquilo fica claro ou não fica, né?
Eh, esse roteiro, ele é a contribuição
do Buda, ele tá trazendo uma listagem de
problemas para nós, né?
Então, o ideal para estudar ele seria
ler ele constantemente para ir guardando
o roteiro e seguindo ele toda vez. Isso,
né? Sempre tá lendo ele, acessando ele.
>> Eu acho que o ideal é eu deixar ele do
lado
enquanto a gente tá fazendo a a prática
item por item. A gente vê um item,
depois passa pro outro item, aí vai
indo.
>> Ah, boa de fazer silenciosa, mas com a
lenda ao mesmo tempo.
>> Isso acessa de novo ali, vê o que que tá
faltando, vai olhando.
>> Achei bom. Obrigado.
>> Tá bom, querido.
Acho que aqui não tem muito para falar,
mas é mais fazer mesmo, né,
>> Lama?
>> Sim.
>> Tem alguém para falar?
>> Pode falar. Não.
Eh, num dos ensinamentos com o G, ele
fez uma pequena meditação em grupo assim
coletiva ali e na felicidade, né, da
gente desenvolver um estado de
felicidade sem motivo nenhum. E eu me
surpreendi assim, aquilo foi simples e
funcionou bem assim, 5 minutinhos, né?
Aí agora eu na nos fundamentos da sessão
plena ali no item 19, entre os os
preceitos, ele menciona assim, ele
treina assim: é um espírito
experienciando êxtase. Eu inspiro
experienciando felicidade.
É dito que um dos efeitos da realização
em Charma é uma bemaventurança, né?
>> Hum. Eu acredito que seria nessa linha e
eu sinto realmente no pelo menos no
começo do da sessão de meditação, eu
consigo
manifestar essa felicidade, mas depois
de uma meia hora, quando começa a doer
aqui, ali, já não é tão fácil assim de
manter esse estado ali também. Depois
ele menciona assim, ele treina assim, é
um espírito contemplando a impermanência
e um espírito contemplando a renúncia.
Nesse caso, a renúncia seria a renúncia
do Sansara.
>> É,
>> né?
E e esse e esse essa sensação de
felicidade, êxtase tem a ver num estágio
mais ele já recomenda para desde o
começo praticar assim, né? Mesmo não
tendo a realização em chama. Mas é, esse
seria um um direcionamento,
>> mas adiante ele vai ficar independente
também disso,
>> como lama. Ele vai, ele tá se
familiarizando com esses estados todos,
né? Eles surgem, cessam, ele vai
reconhecendo que isso é transitório, que
a gente não vai se fixar nisso, né?
>> Seria como um janazinho, uma coisa
assim.
Aqui é um é sate, né? Tudo que aparece
nós vemos, reconhecemos a não dualidade,
reconhecemos o surgimento, sensação e
nos mantemos independentes. Nós estamos
treinando isso.
Que que é uma mente independente de
tudo, de todos os estados mentais? É a
grande abertura. Ela tá viva, mas ela tá
livre.
Por isso que o Buda vai dizer que isso
aqui é o caminho direto.
Em pouco tempo a gente atinge a
realização, porque nós vamos pegando
tudo que desvia as classes e a gente vê,
reconhece aquilo
e se vê independente.
Ama, eh, falando um pouquinho da grande
abertura,
eh,
a grande abertura, ela,
a maneira como eu, eu entendo isso é que
ela não é algo que pertence a um
indivíduo, na verdade.
Eh, ou aliás, seria
nós como indivíduos, a individualidade,
ela surge como uma manifestação dessa
grande abertura?
A individualidade surge como uma
manifestação da grande abertura.
>> E no caso essa grande abertura,
>> manifestação delusiva, né, da grande
abertura. Isso, inclusivo.
E essa grande abertura, portanto, ela
seria o mesmo para cada indivíduo.
>> Ah, eu acho difícil a gente pegar uma
ótica de apontar um objeto e começar a
comparar, sabe? A grande abertura, ela
ela escaparia dos objetos. Então, é
melhor a gente não usar essa linguagem
assim,
né?
Porque a gente, na verdade, começa a
tentar caracterizar o objeto grande
abertura.
Aí nós
melhor não
avançar nessa direção.
Aí tem o eu, tem a grande abertura e eu
começo a olhar a grande abertura.
Aí aquilo vai virando um objeto.
>> Nesse caso, por exemplo, eu teria que
também me perguntar o que que vê a
grande abertura. E aí entra nesse
problema.
>> É, eu começo a criar uma dualidade, né?
Perfeito. Obrigado.
Então nós vamos fazer dedicação.
Que os méritos desse encontro se
expandam e toquem a todos. Que o mestre
universal da paz e da compaixão, sua
santidade da lailama, juntamente com
todos os mestres de todas as tradições
que veiculam essa mensagem, tenho longa
vida. que todos estejam a salvo.
Obstáculo mais destrutivo, que esses
pensamentos nunca surgem nossa mente e
que todos os seres também estejam livres
de pensamentos
ao longo de minhas muitas vidas e até
este momento. Todas as virtudes que ten
alcançado,
inclusive os méritos gerados por esta
prática e todas as que viera conseguir
ofereço para o bem-estar dos seres
sencientes.
Possam a doença, guerra, fome e
sofrimento diminuir para todos os seres,
enquanto sua sabedoria e compaixão
aumentam nesta em vidas futuras. possa
eu claramente perceber todas as
experiências como sendo tão
insubstanciais quanto tecido do sonho
durante a noite e imediatamente
despertar para perceber
sabedoria pura no surgir de cada
fenômeno. possa eu rapidamente alcançar
a iluminação para trabalhar sem cessar
pela liberação de todos os seres budas e
bodissátuas em conjunto, seja qual for a
sua motivação, sua ação benéfica e
preces auspiciosas,
seja qual for a sua onisciência,
realizações e poderes benévolos. E seja
qual for a sua imensa sabedoria,
que igualmente venho para beneficiar os
seres, rogo para que possa alcançar as
mesmas qualidades. Neste exato momento
possam nem mesmo os nomes doença, fome,
guerra e sofrimento
nações da terra, mas possam sim sua
conduta moral, mérito, riqueza e
prosperidade crescer e possam a suprema
bem-aventurança e bem-estar sempre
surgir para elas.
K
Então, boa noite
amanhã.
>> Gratidão.
>> Obrigado.
>> Boa noite
>> noite.
Boa noite.
>> Boa noite, Sanga.
>> Abraço aí, Gil. Tudo de bom.
Boa noite, Lama. Abraço aqui do Texas.
>> A vida não tá fácil por aí.
A carne tá subindo, o café vai aumentar
50%.
Sitação tá grave.
>> Suco de laranja não pode mais tomar.
Café do Brasil não tem mais.
Carne tá ficando mais cara. Gera cara.
>> Tá vendo? Sansara básica Brasil. Café tá
baixando, a carne tá baixando, tá aqui
tá ficando um lugar maravilhoso.
>> Vale mais a pena pegar um avião e aí
tomar um café do que tomar café aqui
agora.
>> É, aí cuida depois não deixa tu voltar.
>> Pois é. Pois é.
>> Sim.
>> Isso com certeza. Isso com certeza.
Tem que imaginar um tempo desse, né, Jú?
>> Como é que pode, né? Como é que pode
realmente
como é que pode? A gente pensa que a
loucura tem limite, mas não tem.
É, e esse é o problema. A gente quando
acha que é o limite, veio. Ou no outro
dia veio uma outra coisa, uma maluca aí,
né? Com essas coisas sério. E outro dia
eu perguntei para um pessoal que tá na
Califórnia, eles me disseram: "Não, isso
não é nada, isso é a loucura do Trump".
Mas esse esquema, eu acho que eles é um
tipo de argumento que foi amortecendo o
pessoal na Alemanha naquela época
também sabe?
>> Aí tu vai achando
só mais uma loucura quando tu vê tu tá
com água pelo pescoço.
>> Com certeza. Com certeza. Tem uma charge
aqui do da revista de New Yorker que
circulou aqui como sendo didática, né?
Aquela famosa as duas rã dentro da
panela, a panela esquentando, né?
>> É. É isso.
>> E a e o Marran falando assim: "Quando eu
penso em saltar, vem mais uma notícia do
do Trump e a gente vai ficando aqui
>> e vai cozinhando ali.
>> E vai cozinhando cozinhando.
>> Devagar vai todo mundo cozinhando aqui.
>> É,
>> é
>> muito impressionante. A gente não pode
imaginar uma coisa dessas, né?
os países para retirar o reconhecimento
de que o CO A2 causa problemas
ambientais.
>> É,
>> você vai, ele vai alterar as leis.
>> é, uma coisa inacreditável assim,
>> é inacreditável.
>> Não sei nem o que dizer, né? É, a gente
olha todos os dias assim, fala assim:
"Como é que pode isso vir de um
estadista, né, de uma pessoa que
teoricamente deveria virem ações no
sentido contrário, né?" É,
>> agora eu me admiro também daqui eu não
tô vendo um movimento. Como é que a
nação americana não não faz nada? Não
acontece,
>> é, não faz nada. Eles não têm essa,
ainda ontem tava vendo eh reportagem
sobre isso, né?
Eh, sobre o desde o movimento dos dos
direitos civis que começaram no Alabama
com Rosa Parques e tal, não se vê mais
nada disso, absolutamente mais nada. Tá
todo mundo anestesiado assim pelo
>> Mas eu não entendo isso, não consigo
pelo É, o máximo de notícias que vê
indignações aqui é quando a bolsa cai.
Aí quando a bolsa cai, ele se indign
>> é terrível, né? É. E daí vem, daí vem
alguns movimentos assim da Califórnia,
vem muitos protestos vindo da Califórnia
e tal, mas é bastante pontuais, nada
muito
muito complexo. Aí
>> tem que decretar a independência do
Texas.
>> É
>> Califórnia
uma coisa assim, os gaúchos são
perigosos, não conseguiram no Rio Grande
do Sul, mas de repente o Texas.
Pois é, exatamente.
Mas é complexo aqui. É complexa a
situação.
>> Complexa. É,
>> a própria mídia, lama, quando acontece
alguma manifestação, a própria mídia
mostra as pessoas sendo presas ou sendo
eh eh maltratadas,
né, com com a polícia maltratando,
batendo e daí reprime essas pessoas, né,
de certa forma ficam eh eh apreensivas e
com medo para não acontecer mais vezes,
né? Então é toda uma jogada de marketing
dentro,
>> traz um traz um medo pras pessoas, né?
>> Isso é
>> é é esse é o clima
>> é
>> é o clima básico.
>> Que estranho isso.
>> Estranho, né?
>> É
>> estranho, né?
Mas é isso, vamos seguindo. Qualquer
coisa, se te prenderem na rua, manda um
whats para nós aqui.
>> É metabana para eles. Vou usar a
estratégia que o Lama fez com o policial
lá quando parou o Lama. Vou metabana
para eles para ver se
[Música]
>> qualquer coisa nós te recebemos aqui com
com o chimarrão.
>> É, pois é. Tem que ser algo pequeno para
chegar algemado.
Tá bom, obrigado por tudo aí.
>> Beijo.
>> Obrigado.
>> Tchau, então.
>> Tchau.
>> Boa noite, pessoal. Coisa tá assim, né?
Que
bom. Um beijo aí.
Boa noite.
Boa noite. Boa noite, Sanga. Obrigada,
Lama.
>> Boa noite.
>> Boa noite a todos.
>> Boa noite, Lama.
>> Boa noite.
>> Até amanhã.
>> Boa noite a todos. Parece que eu já tô
no além. Você não acha assim
>> parecendo mesmo.
>> Ai,
beijo,
>> beijo. Так.